Traductor: Araceli Guanes
Revisor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
En las calles sombrías de un pueblo,
una madre presumía con orgullo
de su hijo recién nacido.
Tras observar su marca de nacimiento,
los vecinos predijeron
que se casaría con una princesa.
Pero los rumores no tardaron en llegar
a oídos del rey malvado.
El rey, enfurecido, atrapó al niño
y lo abandonó río abajo.
Pero la suerte del niño resultó ser mayor
que los planes del rey.
Años después, mientras el rey
paseaba por su reino,
divisó a un joven fornido
con una extraña marca de nacimiento.
Tras confirmar los orígenes del chico,
el rey astuto le confió
una carta para la reina.
El joven partió entusiasmado
a entregar el mensaje...
sin saber que lo que llevaba
era su propia sentencia de muerte.
Aquella noche, unos bandidos que vagaban
por allí toparon con su campamento.
Pero en cuanto leyeron aquella carta cruel
les invadió la lástima.
Así que decidieron mejor molestar al rey
y escribieron una nueva carta.
Cuando el joven llegó al palacio,
cruzó una mirada con la princesa.
Se sintieron destinados
el uno para el otro.
Y cuando la reina leyó que el rey
aprobaba aquel matrimonio
organizó con entusiasmo una boda fugaz.
Cuando el rey volvió, estaba furioso
pero no podía ejecutar
al amor de su hija sin razón.
Así que ideó una prueba diabólica.
Ordenó al joven ir al mismo infierno
y volver con tres cabellos de oro
recién arrancados de la cabeza del diablo.
Solo si lo conseguía,
podría volver con su prometida.
El joven buscó la entrada al infierno
por todo el reino,
hasta que por fin divisó
una misteriosa aldea.
Allí, vio a algunos campesinos
reunidos alrededor de un pozo.
Lo acorralaron y le impidieron el paso
hasta que contestara la pregunta:
¿Por qué estaba el pozo seco?
El joven respondió,
"Contestaré cuando regrese".
Los campesinos guiaron
al joven aldea adentro
donde encontró a otros campesinos
que contemplaban un árbol nudoso.
Se negaron a dejarlo pasar hasta que
les respondiera la pregunta:
¿Por qué el árbol era infértil?
De nuevo, el joven respondió,
"Contestaré cuando regrese".
Los campesinos lo guiaron hasta el muelle
donde un barquero anciano esperaba.
Mientras remaba por las aguas negras,
el barquero arrojó una tercera pregunta:
¿Cómo puedo escapar
de esta tarea interminable?
Una vez más, el joven prometió:
"Contestaré cuando regrese".
Al fin, llegaron a un refugio situado
en las pantanosas orillas del infierno.
El joven llamó a una puerta en mal estado.
La abuela del diablo
contestó a su llamada.
Era conocida por ayudar
a algunos visitantes y hacer daño a otros.
El joven acababa de terminar su historia
cuando escucharon los pasos del diablo.
De repente, el mundo
parecía hacerse más pequeño.
La abuela del diablo dejó al joven
en los pliegues de su manga
y saludó a su nieto.
La anciana se puso a trabajar
y llenó al diablo de comida y bebida.
Cuando este se quedó dormido, le arrancó
hábilmente tres brillantes cabellos.
Con cada cabello que arrancaba, el diablo
despertaba y se quejaba de sus sueños,
llenos de campesinos de la zona
y de sus problemas.
A la mañana siguiente, el joven marchó
con tres cabellos de oro y tres datos.
Compartió el primer sueño
del diablo con el barquero.
Si el barquero conseguía dar los remos
a algún pasajero dispuesto,
quedaría liberado de su tarea.
De vuelta en la ciudad, el joven anunció
que allí había un ratón
royendo las raíces del árbol
y un gran sapo bloqueando el pozo.
Los campesinos lo recompensaron
generosamente por su ayuda.
Al regresar de su viaje, el joven
mostró al rey los cabellos del diablo
pero su avaro suegro
solo tenía ojos para el oro.
El astuto joven le dijo al rey
que una mayor fortuna lo esperaba
cruzando el río.
Inmediatamente, el rey se apresuró
a la orilla del río.
Ansioso de reclamar su fortuna,
tendió impaciente las manos al barquero,
quien, feliz, le entregó sus remos.